all along we've been told this virus
simply does not discriminate and now we
know from cleaners to doctors these NHS
workers who lost their lives to kovat 19
were all at a greater risk they come
from a black Asian or minority ethnic
background and NHS England has confirmed
what many have feared was even discussed
what was gonna happen is those of us got
affected by this Salman is a doctor in
the northwest of England treating kovat
19 patients because of his Pakistani
heritage
he's worried and fears the worst latest
analysis by Sky News suggests that 62%
of the healthcare staff that have died
so far during this outbreak are from
Abbey AME background but only 21% of the
NHS workforce is from this community its
numbers like this that has led to new
guidance for NHS Chiefs to risk assess
their B AME staff one former hospital
boss told us lives could have been saved
if this was brought in earlier but it
comes with challenges taking be army
colleagues out of frontline working on
Kovac Ward's may just not be possible
because we have such a huge dependence
on them certainly in the major
conurbations that you can't you can't
just move half of your start away
because you can't you know don't have
another half to replace them around 18
percent of patients to die in hospitals
in England with Kovac 19 are from ethnic
minorities or mixed backgrounds those
groups make up just 15 percent of the
population the main difference is among
black African and Caribbean patients and
those from other ethnicities including
Arab and Roma but these groups are also
more likely to live in London
which accounts for a quarter of
England's deaths one issue is
overcrowded and multi-generational
households more prevalent in pame
families making it almost impossible to
social distance there is a review from
public health England underway to find
out the exact reasons behind why be AME
people are affected more from this
disease but everyday the corona virus
continues to kill and this data
gathering is limited to those who've
died in our hospitals because of that we
may never know the true proportion of
deaths from these communities in rasheed
Sky News